I love the climb I truly believe the
definition of an entrepreneur is loving
the process more than the things you get
out of it I don't like the stuff I don't
want watches [ __ ] cars
I don't need planes I don't need dick I
need the process I need to buy the Jets
period I truly believe that I will never
really fully capitalize on all the money
or all the opportunities because I think
I always leave a little bit on the table
because I want to keep playing I want to
keep playing and I think that that's the
part that I'm curious about in the
audience which is what's the divide for
you between how much do you want to keep
playing and how much do you want the
fruits that come along with success in
winning the game
I find it stunningly interesting that
you know of course I like like having
money but I am I am equally as happy
right now as I was paying myself twenty
seven thousand dollars a year at 23
years old because the building of the
game and I really do believe that
separates me and the people in this
audience that have that from the people
that don't that they think it's a means
to an end that they'll make more money
doing it themselves versus working for
somebody and to me that's the pure
definition of entrepreneurship
you